and the much anticipated Amazon Prime
days tomorrow and Wednesday a two-day
shopping event where Amazon Prime
members get access to Major Savings in
today's ad on your side
ber gives us the tools to get the best
deals
is it worth all the hype should you be
shopping at the competitor stores
instead very important question says
Savvy Shopper Andrea Warwick when it
comes to Amazon Prime days as long as
you know what to buy she says you'll get
a great deal and the best ones on
Amazon's own products which includes
their Electronics 45 off a ring video
doorbell 45 off the Amazon Fire HD
tablet 75 off Amazon's Fire TV 43-inch
Omni series there are also good deals on
Home Goods kitchen appliances fashion
memberships even Amazon Basics
merchandise there are a lot of sales to
be had but how do you know you're
getting the best deal you have to do
your research especially on price
histories online retailers fluctuate
their prices all the time she says
sometimes they'll even inflate their
original price to make that deal or
discount percent look like a better
value don't be fooled don't let those
big discount claims influence your
purchase be smart research price
histories to determine if now is the
best deal that you're seeing you can do
that by using camelcamelcamel.com to
track prices of items sold on Amazon
it'll show you if the prime Day deal is
the lowest selling price and if it isn't
wait you can also download the honey
browser extension which allows you to
set a sale alert it'll notify you when
the price drops Amazon's app also makes
it easy to track Prime Day sales scroll
through the site on the app hit the
watch this deal icon and it'll alert you
when that item goes on sale on Prime day